hello and happy Monday Mike Meyer cloud
we're back again I guess it's only been
a week and you're very loud yeah I know
I got to turn myself down I'll do that
in a second oh yeah I was on with you
into the breach was a good call yeah and
today I hit you up last Friday I was
like dude got a I got a good stream for
Monday if you want to join me it's a
game that we both really loved and won
our game of the year and 2015 right yeah
and looking back at it I was it just
made me remember how salty I was that we
didn't push for it to be higher but it
is what it is we got it to four minor I
don't know it's up to you um I'll do
I'll do yes
yeah we're gonna start a new character
in play I have a save I told you I was
doing a recent play through that
threaded cane recently I got to uh
what's the name of the boss at the end
of the unseen village the one reborn is
that it the one I believe that is
correct I believe that is correct just
so you guys know if you guys haven't
played blood-borne or if you're looking
into it for whatever reason it's free I
believe tomorrow as a playstation if you
have PlayStation Plus as part of the
free kind of like PlayStation Plus games
or being a PlayStation Plus member what
are you gonna what are you gonna do here
I'm probably I don't know for the sake
of not screwing up too badly on the
stream I might just go with the saw Oh
build wise yeah we'll get to a weapon in
a second here but what should my name be
I don't know that's from like Oh Game
Informer days sure that was I thought
you're gonna go butts butts butts 4:20
but that's what I'm going ml and like
everything lately I think I don't know
I'll just maybe just do default age
although yeah I just did that this
morning to I was like I'm gonna go real
old man okay so this is the one that
this is where it matters the most Wow
you're gonna play here I don't know so I
was doing the blood tinge and
what else was it for the threaded cane
price skill skill and think what going
to English oh that's I mean professional
would be good yeah yeah yeah just skill
and general I'll just go with the
probably just strength maybe balance
lone survivor is pretty bad these are
I'll go lone survivor um
parents don't need that actually yeah
let me just randomize this also hello to
everyone in the chat I will be kind of
monitoring chat so if you guys have
questions you know comments there we go
that's really good oh you just did the
yelling on V yeah some kind of like yeah
cool cool cool looks good to me
sure yeah I should yes yes father guess
gone today however you want to pronounce
his last name I still don't know how
Gascoigne gets going did you ever so for
the longest time and I still haven't
done it this way but like did you ever
get the music box I've never fought him
with the music box oh yeah I heard it's
like 10 times easier what that means um
yeah if you use it right wait so you
know how to get it though right yeah you
gotta like go to like talk to the door
like kid the kid with like mom dies
whose mom died near father guess going
and you you can go back and tell her
that her mom died and she'll go to the
chapel or shoulder the chapel later but
uh yeah you the music I can show the
music box you just play it and twice in
the fight it'll stun him kind of yeah I
got to the point where I got pretty good
at staggering him yeah which is I don't
really do visceral attacks that much I'm
not I'm not a risky I'm all about it
maybe we'll play it maybe I'll jump on
later a little bit just to mix it up a
little bit but I'll let you get through
most of this I'm just like the wolf kill
me right away usually I try to do the
karate chop yeah
good luck I always tried to kill the
wolf and then usually don't because like
oh you're just gonna let him cool that's
fine
we're not speedrunning for the person
that said speed run although John Luke
has kind of like assured the challenge
between the three of us you me and John
Luke to speed run heat speed around the
game but I fees actually speed run spent
sped ran speed
ran the game and I don't think you have
I definitely have it myself recently I
played through in like a day and a half
I got to the one reborn if that is his
name I don't know I don't know I've
beaten the game fully I think only twice
and then no no no no sorry three times
the third time I've repo started you
know so you platinum then did you plan
on the game no I still have a challenge
dungeon trophy I didn't get the waiting
when old hunters came out I start a new
game because I was at Amelia and in a
New Game+ and I was just getting screwed
up so I think I just want to play old
hunters answer knowing block oh nine hi
don't know this game please define this
game okay so if you know anything about
Dark Souls games this is better I have
to agree with that yeah I personally
agree with that but I've got my order
from games I can share that after ok but
yeah basically sorry actually ok we have
the stream why don't you go oh yeah sure
alright I just want to go with the
basics aw then we're guaranteed you'll
be fine either way dude you gotta
believe on your gameplay but here we'll
ask how about this we'll ask and then if
you feel really not the cane that was my
most recent playthrough and I also did
not pick the right build for that I'm
going saw cleaver ok ok do it I'll see
what people say alright what do you guys
want do you want the saw cleaver or the
Hunter X cuz he's not gonna play 30k I
actually hate threaded cane - everybody
say yeah dude I love the hunter axe
though I thing was beat alright fine
then I'm gonna go pistol please do
pistol ok think I want blunderbuss last
night I need pistol for sure because I
will stagger all day but yeah it's it's
harder than is this harder than in Dark
Souls 3 oh yeah you think so yes Dark
Souls 3 was easy I thought hmm ok so I I
was reviewing it the first time play
Dark Souls 3 so I kind of had to blow
through a you watched him a lot of mine
yeah yeah we work today we work together
on that one I believe for the Dark Souls
yeah yeah so so my order of games is
from I know there's there's like also
like you go farther back there's like
the Tower games and then you go even
farther back and there was the games
from started with but in terms of the
souls borne games
I'm blood-borne in Dark Souls 1 the
in Souls Dark Souls 3 Dark Souls 2 okay
I like Dark Souls 3 bandits still very
good but I don't think it's uh yeah it's
on par with the I can't I can't totally
give the same order cuz I didn't beat
Demon Souls Dark Souls 1 or Dark Souls 2
so I only have Dark Souls 3 and
blood-borne in under my belt I played
like a little bit of demon souls on
stream with John Luke but uh yeah I can
see your order I can understand why that
would be the order um the other thing
too was there's a lot of people actually
that said ax sorry it's uh it's all good
sorry about that guys
but someone also said axes easy mode
says freeform roles I think that Saul
cleaver is actually easier than the act
ax has more reach in power but it's
slower though yeah this thing is so fast
and the you don't need to worry about
timing as much the softly you just
unless it's something you can't stagger
and you'll have enough strength and I
feel like the switch the switch this the
switch mode of the the saw cleaver is so
good because it gives you more range
right it like you do like the you do
though that twice and then you like
extend it I don't just like never use it
yeah I'm not with a threaded cane I use
the whips wit form a lot but the saw
cleaver I just kind of stick with the
blade Oh Ben genka wants in on that
blood borne race I don't know man I'm
not a speed runner I'd have to look at
the speedruns and I know there's like
some weird like hoppy glitches that you
can do to like you know jump past
certain areas and whatnot but yeah yeah
no yeah I like speed run watching
speedruns a lot I don't like doing them
cuz I oh I feel like every time I speed
runs I try to speed around something and
I haven't done it much I just it ruins
my personal enjoyment playing the game I
love watching that stuff like ocarina
speedruns and yeah
the half-life 2 speedruns with the mega
jump on them with like the rockets and
stuff like that yeah okay here's here's
a good one because this will this will
enter into like another one of those fun
debates is like what do you think is the
hardest boss in the souls War series
because hold on let me give you the name
of the person that said orphan of cost
dang it or is it okay I'm sorry if I
missed the name I should have looked
that up too but he basically the the the
chatter said that for them they felt
like orphan of cost was the hardest boss
in the souls Bourne series now I haven't
played that some of the older
so I have to ask you me yeah I can see
that Becky like God must have died like
14 times but it's weird um the first
time I ever played blood-borne the Blood
star beast was like awful for me I think
I died maybe 20 times and that's more I
consider myself pretty decent at these
kind of games and I'm one of those
people who will say like when you really
get down to it if you're patient and
know what you're doing they're not all
that terribly hard but obviously that's
easy to say right up until you start
screwing up and dying on a boss like 12
times yeah
cause I could see that by her I don't
know I think I'm trying to think of like
Dark Souls yeah well it wasn't Artorias
like pretty hard yeah I I didn't have as
much trouble as a lot of people but
definitely I could I can definitely see
though I [ __ ] know what's his name
Ludwig in the old hunters oh dude yeah
that that guy gave me problems he was
probably one of the heart I mean over
the cost was also hard for me but I
remember Ludwig was this weird kind of
like almost like gear check kind of like
hey Ida cool yeah he was a pretty hard
one that was from I'm on beep Kumar so
you know if you guys in chat wanna you
know put in your two cents about who you
think is the you know hardest boss in
the souls Bourne series go for it and
we'll talk about some of those or I'll
have to defer to my con some but from
what I'll try to turn what I'm laying
Demon Souls lately he's doing a feature
on it soon yeah so the cool thing though
I read is that like people have tried to
like kind of keep that alive with the
with the private servers which is pretty
cool yeah sure sorry I'm no I'm not to
the point in the game I mean obviously
you can [ __ ] up at any point these games
I'm not there yet I'm nervous I hate the
pitchfork dudes
yeah they got that reach me yeah it's
the reach but I also like somehow never
figure it out or I mean I do but you
[ __ ]
so for those who haven't played it even
though I think most people have the
reason why this game was a little bit
like more accessible because this was
the first one I played is because they
have that kind of the dodging is good
and also like you get the re you regain
health from actually being aggressive
and your endure I mean Dark Souls 3 kind
of took a little more from this
afterward but your endurance going back
to any game before this your endurance
refills so much faster yeah Dark Souls 3
again like you could build your
character I mean you could build your
character to do that but by default this
game is not more forgiving maybe but it
just demands a different kind of play
style and this is more suited to my play
style and I can see this is closer than
what you play this game is closer to
more like character action games like
DMC or guys were so I could see why I'm
not accessible
yes not as I mean anytime anybody
compares a game to the souls born games
or Dark Souls specifically it's they're
usually trying to say it's deliberate
because you can't cancel attacks you
can't you have to like think right
before you attack and you're kind of
actually you have to commit to attacks
and you have to deliberately like plan
it out a little more like even Monster
Hunter you kind of have to do that
that's why it's not the difficulty that
I compared souls born games to other
games it's the that deliberate nature
and the other thing too was like after I
mean having not played Dark Souls yeah
they had see you're gaining later your
life back but you can actually keep
hitting them as if dead which is
interesting to get life back to time I
do a playthrough it takes me a little
while to get back into that muscle
memory to remember that the other thing
too was like I know that Dark Souls you
know for the most part you had to you
know use your your flasks your Estus
flasks and we're not in this one-handed
those you can kind of farm up the
potions a bit more in this one but I
think you could do that was it human
souls you could also do that in one of
the older ones also had something very
similar
yeah yeah cuz I mean three was just like
two and one where you had to actually
upgrade your allotment of a snus flasks
that's this class who would who would
you say this is from kurma the
nine-tailed Fox which bosses or which
boss did you struggle with the most
probably orphan of cost or what about in
taxes darks yeah what about what about
just blood warm proper I'm not born the
expansion a lot to start the first time
play through his blood start beast but
then I like in my recent playthrough I
smoke him on the second try I think mmm
trying to think of who else in this game
I'm redoing Amelia on New Game+
to get to old hunters before I start a
new game gave me a lot of trouble
because just that healing that she does
yeah some people shouting out John Povey
said Rama was tricky for me yeah ROM so
if you because everybody was telling me
don't worry about the little spiders but
then once I started actually killing the
little spiders I was fine yeah because
like the thing is you can take that
approach but you're kind of like hiding
a lot to try to get space right but like
by killing some of the smaller spiders
it then allows you to kind of like more
freely move around so different approach
there obviously um to m8y for you says
bear man was tough jaegerman is pretty
pretty difficult and to me guys i I'm
good with those fast bosses yeah I am
too for some reason I struggle with the
larger bosses for whatever reason I'll
[ __ ] this guy luck is this gonna be
death number one and so for the person
who didn't know now that you died he has
accumulated souls which he has to use
her blood echoes sorry blood echoes in
this game that he has to use to level up
but in order to get the blood echoes
that he just earned he has to go back
and get those but if he doesn't then he
loses whatever he lost it's probably not
that bad in the beginning so yeah oh
let's see you know was actually what is
the way you really take over some
talking right well I mean you happen but
sure enough sorry I'm gonna get to using
a focus ease all right what was actually
tough for me when I remember wasn't act
like an actual boss
and I think I eventually figured them
out but like there's like three hunters
I was just gonna say at the beginning in
the unseen village yeah you can yeah
they thought they saw one had the cannon
one hand the flame thing and then put
your shield down and then one had the
threaded cane yeah they all have
different weapons today all those took
me oh I had to really farm blood echoes
because they kept sorry blood vials
because they start smoking me at a sweet
boys guys are ridiculous
I think it's stagger you and everything
it was just nuts I had to like item in
our in like that like a sterile area to
try to lab but you also people are
saying oh no just um you can blur them
back to the spawn point only one will
come in at a time and I was like okay
cool that sounds awesome and then like
two came over a lot of people saying
Maria was tough yes for some reason I
got really lucky with Maria she is she
can be a tough boss I - or three shot at
her but I got lucky I'm pretty sure I
got lucky against there sometimes you
know you just get lucky or something I
was like I feel like sometimes even the
first time you fight a boss somehow you
do better than the next like two or
three tries for whatever reason is so
weird there were a bunch of bosses even
on a deprived running darksouls three
arrived I mean I I've one shot so many
bosses in Dark Soul 3 compared to any
other Souls boring game I remember the
first time I played who are the twins
that you fight those not the twins but
like the two assassins in the chapel
your Dark Souls 3 right yeah I'm really
I myself I'm not good with big bosses
but I'm really good with like what's the
one in this one shadow of yharnam the
three
I'm good those kind of ones but I just
like I only get my health back way
I'm good with those like I can crowd
control shut off your arm you got that
pillar in the center that you can use to
stop the the range attacks from coming
at you yeah apparently that it's not the
threaded cane Wade B McGuinness wants
you to know it's the pimp cane like way
it's not
Maria is for the weave heck yeah that's
fine I'm a weed honest question did you
practice before this livestream no well
no I mean why did I start a new
playthrough a couple weeks ago I
just cuz I like because the game is
great yeah I said I mean no I haven't
played in maybe three weeks Oh actually
no I was playing right before shadow
costs and monster hunter came out so my
life was like one boss fight after
another
yeah you're just yeah I like your style
here you're not afraid I definitely I
definitely this is where the the the
threaded King comes in handy every [ __ ]
like this I definitely pulled three or
four at a time here I like was too
afraid to upset the village it's alright
you'll just get it back the beauty of
blood-borne yeah a lot of people also
saying neo is a good game and that there
was a lot from blood feeling love me
yeah I like neo a lot too but something
about blood-borne for me is is there but
I do like that
neo kind of went into like another kind
of like genre so much but like time
period like different type of style
because my friend that didn't like
blood-borne at all somehow beat me oh
you know cuz he liked us style I love
that there's this like versioning
sub-genre I mean not it's not it's have
been having for a while I mean I didn't
like was that mech game last year yeah
it was was a call it was like ad it was
an adjective right or a verb you know
I'm talking about when not that mech
you're not I'm actually of like cyborgs
robot or surge surge like surge at all I
was 9 a little clunkier it's the same
guys as Lords of the Fallen and I didn't
like Lords the Fallen no no I um and I
didn't like Lords the Fallen Lord the I
get what they were doing Lords the
Fallen I'm gonna go get my souls from
this t-shirt but I really liked neo cuz
I actually saw it fine ok maybe not
damnit get up while you're talking about
that yeah someone brought up a good
point in chat that the hunter from the
Eileen Quest is actually a pain in the
butt to that guy is a stud like I don't
know if you've ever fought him but that
guy is straight-up a stud [ __ ] oh
the hunter in initially before I figured
out you could just keep shotgunning him
off the ledge the hunter in what was uh
what's it called what's the first
optional area in blood-borne oh the
machine gun on the left is when you go
down and go to the left uh god that hunt
that guy that was annoying not on scene
village it's something it's one star
beast
it's where blood start beast is
forgotten he he took me a while but and
then I realized oh I could just shock on
him off the ledge I kept rolling until I
got him to roll oh yeah it was like Dark
Souls 3 that first guy with the with the
katana you can get him to kind of roll
off the ledge that was the best yeah and
where is he at let's see he's an old
knee Arnim old yharnam thank you yeah
you're on after but then after wells ago
he's actually not that hard
alright let me count let me yeah come
let's you definitely pick it up for free
if even if you don't play it right away
you should just make sure you download
it cuz that's just how ps+ games work so
if you don't have always be worth your
time yeah definitely this is not as good
as I was doing on my Extra Life
playthrough rightfully I don't think I
died maybe it's cuz I'm having you talk
more than you you want to
oh holy bully don't buy the game you're
gonna get it for free if you have
PlayStation Plus tomorrow so just way
today I believe it's tomorrow
yeah even if you don't a place it's like
probably worse I mean like what games
like blood-borne coming to it it'll be
worth it down the road I'm not trying to
just sell PlayStation Plus to people but
I mean yeah there's been some good ones
I remember like one of the first big
ones that we got for free and part of
the reason why I think it's helped
succeed or help that game succeed was
rocket League oh yeah for sure yeah that
wouldn't have exploded as much if it
wasn't a subscriber game um cult chasing
chalice dungeons takes some time getting
used to but its own the best content in
the game if you try it out and don't
skip them so cool J I kind of agree with
you and I kind of don't um if you do
chalice dungeons enough you start to
realize a lot of the tile sets have the
same patterns and just kind of annoying
a boring after but there are whoops
there are some cool bosses in there that
I would say one of the best boss fights
that I experienced just because it was
like pretty creepy was that the
and Queen if I think I'm saying that
right and she's only in the chalice
dungeons and she is a tough boss and
like you just have to you just have to
like experience it I like all I can say
is she is like she has a good I want to
say it's either like the stories like
her child she had like miscarriage or
something but basically like the baby
will cry as she's like it's it's really
trippy you can watch a video on it if
you guys want but she is a fun fight
but the chalice dungeons also were
slightly annoying in the sense that you
had to get all those materials to unlock
other ones and you needed specific ones
I mean it's dealing with these riflemen
so [ __ ] awfully and then have you
seen some of those uh those bosses that
like we are in the game but then didn't
actually make like they're not actually
part of the main game but people have
found them some of those are like trippy
they're definitely not as refined but
people have found them in the game like
trying to think of an example I know
there's two of them there's at least two
if not three that people have found that
are like in some weird areas and most of
the video I've seen like the people have
smoked them but like it could just
because they're high level or those
monsters or just not like tuned or
whatever yeah you won't get DLC as
Amandeep Kawara says but still
blood-borne the base game will still
take you a long while to beat and if
that gets you to you know into the
series or into the genre like it did for
me that's already like again in my
opinion what working with such a god I
love this game um it was it is great for
how it got people into it was such a
good balance of like getting people into
the series but also remaining like its
own thing yeah but like to your point
about neo being set in medieval
supernatural Japan as opposed to
Victorian kind of like London almost so
to speak Lovecraftian Victorian era I do
love this setting but I actually really
liked Neos the use of its of its setting
as well
much Doge very while says do you guys
think from software was teasing
bloodborne - at the Game Awards as much
as I I went to a deep dive spiral trying
to figure out what it was and as much as
everyone wants a blood-borne - I don't
think that T's was for blood-borne - I
think it was for something else that
they've been working on yeah and I don't
think we're gonna find out until maybe
hope that alluded to their earlier games
tenchu I think it is who is the quote or
the little line that God dropped is well
they said that the boss says that
something like that like he has a quote
but then other people are saying it
might not be tend to you and when
something outside of its old boring
games I'm not super familiar with them
you know from software stuff and I'm
pretty sure
Miyazaki's working on Armored Core as
his next like whatever that is that
whatever next version of Armored Core is
but that's what he's working on and I'm
kind of weary of them trying to do a
blood-borne game without him even if
he's only like consulting cuz wasn't he
only consulting on Dark Souls 2 and two
and three
no no three he he was on three yeah and
then two was the one he'd consulted on
and two is the one that everyone hates
so like I don't want a rushed - it was
still like I think relatively a good
game but because the raster right it's
the weaker come it's got some persons
for sure silently kill this troll I'm
trying to think if I'm gonna have to I'm
definitely gonna have to like pour a few
things and before I fight cleric beast I
think maybe not uh
I did like the chalice dungeons for the
different bosses but again the tile sets
eventually got kind of old but it did it
was fun in the sense that I think it was
like knock meet me Nico see 77th and
said which was like he had a lot of fun
farming like perfect gems you know that
you can enhance your weapons which was
really cool obviously Blackbird says why
in your opinion of this game is one of
the best for you
I'll let Mike go first I think it's for
us as ps4 though right like best for us
on Pete one of the best on ps4 for SES
for games
one of us ps4 games yeah I just I think
it's like such a great balance between
[ __ ] you sorry hold on a second
no worries I'll go and then you can
chime in
how about that yeah one of the reasons
why repeat I personally like blood-borne
so much especially on ps4 as of one of
the best games I played on ps4 is one it
was the first game that got me into this
type of John this genre of games I
thought I was never gonna play a Dark
Souls game because my perception of it
was that you know it was like oh this
games like really slow I have to block a
lot that's not my style it looks very
hard it looks very unforgiving shield
she's getting sorry oh no that's
upstairs sorry yeah but works that's
what it was you liked this game promotes
aggression it it just had a faster pace
to it and then once I got into playing
this game I love this game and now I'm
totally into like you know all the souls
style of games and whatnot and so for
that reason and because of like the
level that the music box is right in
that window oh nice okay and obviously
it takes a while to get to but that's it
the level design is so amazing just like
the appreciation you can have for like
once you figure out like oh this
shortcut goes here and this one goes
here and it all is like part of just
like this kind of like one big tile set
and you're just like that's kind of cool
so that's most of the reasons why and
the weapons are cool I think some of the
weapons some of the armor yeah I mean
thing that like any time I'm talking
about I'm fascinated with level design
in general whether it be open-world or
linear stuff or every time people talk
about the comma in this I feel like they
fit not all the time like a lot of times
people fail to mention the level design
I think that is what makes these games
so good is the level design I think if
you had to point to one thing Dark Souls
3 is level design was really good it got
more vertical than most of the other
ones had been a Dark Souls pretty
vertical Dark Souls was also more about
like figuring out which way you could go
and almost a more traditional RPG sense
like oh [ __ ] I'm way under level for the
fortress right now or for Blighttown
whatever you want to say but like in
this it does such a good job like you
said I'm liking a shortcut yeah we're
pretty much okay sorry some cases like
it's a bigger deal than beating a boss
like yeah and it'll allow you to farm
way easier way more easily if you need
to it eases that tension that you have
did I go too far out do I want to go
back and then once you find the shortcut
oh thank god yeah
like let's just go back now and they'll
come back I mean I remember you were
watching me when I was reviewing Dark
Souls 3 I was playing in the office and
parties I always feel terrible about
this I was in the first Cathedral you go
to and I'm about to die and I had like
maybe a quarter health left and I was
just really lagging and then all of a
sudden I found the shortcut yeah oh yeah
I remember you open the door you're like
oh yeah yeah Church that's the first
time I play it's my gosh I don't know
where this is going
watch out for the Gatling gun you got
there dude I don't think it turns around
less you get closer in there yeah you
still think so
but yeah these dudes can direct you if
you're not ready yeah
but yeah this the level design of this
is like I'm trying to think of other
games like half-life 2 that compare on
ps4 there's very little that compares in
terms of levels not saying there's not a
lot of good games with levels I'm saying
this is so far above like level design
wise on anything like on anything else
on ps4 exclusive wise or xbox for that
matter I mean like for it's weird like
comparing this to like when I think of
good levels and I think of like 3 Mario
games as well and like this is on par
with whatever the games trying to do
this just nails it yeah perma good at by
saying like you know if you are gonna
think about playing the DLC make sure
you don't beat the bots last boss cuz
you know otherwise you're gonna have to
do it any game Plus which is fair I'm
gonna go back and work but so Kevin you
can't what I didn't get any insight no
it's not oh is it just based on the
insight I thought it yeah cuz your first
insight you get is from Clarice right
yeah yeah ok so I thought I was like oh
yeah you can't do it till cleric because
the dark basically the doll won't wake
up to all right anyway I'm like okay
yeah with a shortcut you can avoid the
two wolves too if you want to cuz you go
up til no I know you mean yeah I guess
I'll do that I gotta remember obviously
to go back to past the two wolves to get
the old hunter garb oh sorry yeah you
want the whole set you want the whole
set yeah it's a I think the sewer yeah I
should do that before cleric peace
yeah you could do that you we have
plenty time dude and you go as long as
we want today is how I look at it
farik's Academy if I'm gonna play this
later on stream maybe I can hop in for
like 15 20 minutes later and Mike and we
can swap roles but I'm gonna let me go
for a bit yeah for those people
wondering why I'm flying after they're
dead
you keep getting held back if you hit
them even if their health is gone arrow
LM saying I must be in the minority that
doesn't want a sequel to blood-borne I
think that's reasonable I mean I just
want one because like I like the game so
much like I'll just play another one
yeah but you know I can also see the
argument for you know neo I never beat
it
I beat neo I didn't beat all the DLCs
and someone in chat earlier sorry for
forgetting your name I had mentioned
that the DLCs of neo were harder and I
agree with that 100% harder than harder
than the base game yeah the the DLC like
old hunters in some ways was harder than
I mean basic neo in general I found much
harder than blood-borne or any souls
game wu-tang wu-tang Dan says saw
cleaver purist here alright so the
prison ex was going I was going simple
excellent weapon although yeah I still
prefer it I would want to do here oh if
you want the armor around
alright good luck just gotta he's gotta
learn many I do one at a time for sure
for me I use Ludwig's holy bloody effort
through the first place you know saw
clear and they're solid and then my
second playthrough I went more skill
tinged and I would I want a guy mad at
me yet yep yeah let's do it
Chicago's very fun yeah I mean if you
can deal with like I don't know the cane
for the first while
you know get up
no all right leave my soldier right
there are you gonna have to kill one for
it
arrow M's Acker camera boy in case you
were wondering if I was practicing
before this just kind of proves I wasn't
right into the fray her cameras dope I
thought it was really cool and I like I
was like oh conceptually like I'm gonna
use this weapon and then the hammer was
just too slow for me so then once I
found Ludwig's blade
I don't know I think just like the
moveset and the range of like the great
kind of great sword the Lucas that is
essentially the cleaver but longer
reaching almost like almost all the
moves were the cleaver it's just it's
simple but really effective yeah cuz I
like the the single sword as well as the
the two-handed sword so I was like all
this works out but yeah I just stick to
the one-handed for the most part but
like I was telling you I kind of don't
you don't switch you don't trick it I
threaded cane I kind of had to mmm
because of the reach on that
without a knot in whip form in the
actual cane form
okay I'm feeling good about blood cleric
beast under guard I mean like the other
thing you can do too if you're oh look
who had them if you're loving that
happens if you're worried about it is
like hey you can Molotov the [ __ ] out of
ya I usually do just cuz I don't I
always forget to use them after the
Clarisse oh good start
excellent start see ya ready boy Durham
just not having enough endurance for
stuff like this one period here comes
what I learn into it you know how you
can choose this what go back down the
stairs
yeah the door and I'll do just choose it
and when you get around this dude and
then fight oh not can I get around him
that way
the other ones taking a break oh not
anymore he's back
that was a there you go right in the he
was being a bad boy
okay so much Doge very well good a good
question here what do you guys think of
code vain some people are writing it off
because of his style okay so I'm
interested in beds late it's like
graphic novel or know it's like anime
anime styled like Dark Soul and usually
be ended up yeah exactly so here's the
thing though right so I'm I'm excited
but cautiously excited because sorry I'm
going down this way right yeah yeah yeah
and then down goodbye little drop down
the premise and stuff like that is like
awesome because like you know I wanna I
want to anime Souls II game sure of
course
that's pretty cool however when I was
watching gameplay of like Dave playing
Cobain against like a boss or something
did you do a preview yeah I was like a
preview what I noticed is that you have
like like a sidekick character and I I
don't know that's not yeah well I was
thinking those okay I don't know if
she's there the entire time
however if he is it kind of feels like
it takes away from some of the tension
that I have playing like something like
this you can do that you can summon
people in this but it's not default I'm
a purist or neatest what
I don't want the help right people so
the thing is in that game like if she
really if the psychic is really there
the whole time
it's like the boss targets the other
person like it targets your your AI
helper in which case that takes away for
me the tension that I would have had
fighting the boss by myself
because it's being distracted so I I
haven't played it yet so I can't like
definitively say that's gonna ruin my
experience for me but that is definitely
a thing that might ruin my experience
because you know it's not there it's up
top no I know it or no it's down below
but it's all the other end I'm just
trying to member if like one I should
drop that oh no there's a post up here I
can drop on to it gets me nothing bono
technically I could I could get the
madman's knowledge first before I feel
better take the insight yeah okay that's
fair if I wanted to but I usually just
fight them Clara P sorry I decide blood
start beasties why Perry the crap out of
these a gun pay I don't know I don't
think opens resistor all attacks I don't
really I'll be the guy I'm more I'm
aggressive but not not like that because
I didn't have the timing down when my
first playthrough and I didn't have the
guts to do it that much but now that I
kind of know what to do I know a lot of
their cues yeah and the thing is and the
beauty of pairing once you kind of get
used to it is that even if you take
damage if you parry and you do your
visceral attack you generally get most
of that life back yeah and there's the
ruins later on that make it even more
worth it so like that's the other thing
there's the other layer there that like
you probably won't even get to see too
much today but you you have ruins that
you get to put into your hunter that
will kind of affect your place that a
little bit and then also you know
there's some that like have it refill
like 50% you're healthy or something
that's the ones Lakes room I forget what
it's called exactly but like yeah I
definitely use that one because I was
just rolling oh god I had him yeah this
guy's this guy's gonna goes ham I
thought I had him before me
yep left yeah [ __ ] on what we didn't
know better this is a good piece free
set of armor that you can get if you
just walk down here into the sewers
pretty good one it's really it's
compared to your normal stuff it's like
improvement on everything yes you look
though so this makes the clarity all
that much easier
I mean he's not gonna be easy but I I
guess he could be compared I'm I'm not
gonna even like based on how I've been
playing today I'm not gonna call any
shots and alright alright that's very
cool see no worries kill me knowledge
down right man's knowledge is in the
canal with the boats on the other side
of where I like a work kind of where I
leans that right and the pig yeah well
you're gonna have to go that way later
to get the shortcut your Gascoigne so
it's the opposite way of the pig like
it's the same like yeah I know what
you're talking about canal but it's the
other end of it you can technically drop
down then yeah if it's down where you
say it is I forget it is yeah how many
times have they died we died three times
I think I'm going somewhere two or three
Pierre Thomas Kirk hammer for the win
nice didn't um what's his name with the
metallic eye dude Kirk [ __ ] I wanted to
say Cobain but it's definitely Herc
[ __ ] I should I can look it up for you
that's what I shouldn't even need to
like people gonna think I'm so got
Metallica I have net worth Kirk Hammett
yeah he had mentioned he tweeted about
the Kirk hammer once saying something
about how it's so close to his name or
something he was really funny nice go
back up here drop down
should I go fight blood start now or go
yeah I don't want to go alright I might
as well
nASA says what do you guys think of the
drop rated neo do you guys think it was
a bit excessive oh I felt like maybe not
excessive but I did feel like I was I
mean I like that aspect of the game yeah
I mean you weren't getting like I mean
like you were getting a bunch of stuff
but then it wasn't always what you
wanted right so I think it's fine I
don't know oh please don't say that I'm
on deep says code main seems like the
next Lord of the fallens then it's
definite I'm definitely nice to play
then sorry - Lord of the ball and
you know and and Serge likers or lovers
I just it just didn't feel as good I
don't know what it just it was just an
that feels good
alright so here we go damn messes
walkthrough Sesker camera [ __ ] wait I
don't even have any what do I have
molotovs no idea yeah you get them all
the second those oh yeah I guess I'll
put throwing knives they're very least
aligned you can stagger big bosses yeah
I'm not gonna just have to figure out
what their weakness is like Amelia's
like whatever he's like we use likes to
cleric beast like yeah you did that was
George of dogs right oh yeah yeah that's
the back door to the shortcut cleric
beast is optional yeah well he is in the
sense that you don't have to fight him
but like you do get the insight if you
want it or he could get it like these
guys are the funnest attacker because
they got the slowest ass attack yeah but
I also I want it's just they're so easy
once you've dodged to their rock hand
whatever their weapon is it's a brick I
reckon our stone piece of stone look at
birdie oh and they always give you blood
vials to these dudes mm-hmm
I hate those birds I know they're easy
but they're so [ __ ] annoying yes
that's why is the threaded cane is
actually good for them but one thing I
actually like the dead you gain here oh
I remember that cold Jay he says anyone
remember that one child sunjin where the
blood start beast that was Game one on
steroids I died a lot to that guy let's
our piece of tags are hard to time are
hard to the dodges are hard to time with
him I might have missed another comment
from raking blade but they he or she
said I know but that's going to own me
so bad okay here we go let's see how
this goes
I should be fine wait D McGinnis Erik
you wound me yeah I don't Kirk Cameron
is cool in concept but I just weaponize
I was not I was not a big fan hello
once I go I'm gonna shut up for a while
alright good luck you want the music up
I can't I'll shut up to you
no not that far sorry that's like two
more piercing I'm already not doing well
I'm all topping Hey OOP
Jesus good start Mike she's us
you can keep talking I'm just okay I
just wanted to have a nice little
appreciation for some gameplay and so we
can listen to the good music like all
the boss music is so great yeah
big boss 96 says their favorite heroes
are heroes the frame rises sometimes in
this nude wig gurmann and lady Maria are
the best for him yeah that's actually
pretty good pretty good
ooh yeah that's a good call to martyr at
ligarius is it is a good one too he's in
the optional area to cainhurst he's on
top of him that's the dude you used to
get cheap action are you fellas you
didn't to get your pocket that was the
first time I ever had my own little Dark
Souls II moment where I oh [ __ ] good
dodge where I actually read the text of
the item and was like what if I put the
crown on it I was like holy [ __ ] I yeah
I like when it like a random just
utterly random and I was like there is a
cutscene there's another area what the
crazy that was a very memorable moment
for me I still haven't beat the cleric
boss yet well yo you just gotta keep
trying TM soy or so whitey spam those
Molotov easy I'm all togs help too if
you want to do that if you pick them up
yeah I'm not taking I pretty good
against clarity's if he's made of
daggers and Street yeah he's got fur
that burns really easy but as in all
these games I could [ __ ] up at any
moment
mm-hmm yeah get one shotted john Povey
we're playing on just a normal ps4 cuz
that's why I was on my desk we did show
it but no that's my last month oh I
don't owe you my burn yeah he's dead
[ __ ] I was just about to say should I be
a [ __ ] and finishing with a Molotov
there you go your [ __ ] okay nice hey
one shot no problem harder
easier than two wolves yeah awesome
orphan of cost is awesome fight as well
yet for the longest time I thought there
would be some trick with all those guys
that were like praying thinking like
there was something there but they're
just really nothing there okay so here's
a problem I had with Dark Souls 3 I feel
like a a few too many of its bosses
relied on those like gimmicks like
tricks like you don't have to the music
box against guests going and you don't
have to do the sort of what is it storms
against your m-- but it
you had two against you you technically
do but if you want to chip away for
maybe 45 minutes you don't have to no I
don't like that I would have rather dad
throws [ __ ] out the window I like your
skills and that's why I didn't like and
it did that with someone else later in
that game I mean all the games kind of
do that but he was a main you had you
one of the four is one of the four or
five the Kings four and then
what's-his-name the prince who wasn't
that hard he was kind of hard for me he
was cool I thought that fight was cool
for me
I'm weren't there because they kind of
liked win that they it was a twins and
they fought together boy but yeah I
really didn't like that you know you
progressed like I was like what
two-thirds of the game at least half way
something like that half way two-thirds
and like you know you've been doing all
this stuff to like level up get better
at the game and then they're like oh you
kind of have to use this one weapon to
really you know damage you know yeah the
boss essentially so blood-borne is very
different obviously you can just pour
blood echoes into vials if I so choose
choose to do so I can also spend the
insight which you have on items the
insight is something that effects the
game too you can make the game easier by
having a less insight yeah which I never
want certain bosses that seem certain
things it's cool trade-off but about the
witch of charnel lane she always she was
alright yeah she was pretty easy once
you figure her out
kind of but what i really liked with the
old hunters dlc i don't know if he's a
real [ __ ] later on do you think a
spoiler territory you know i guess not
really right the games right now for so
long i guess is the fact that you can um
you can actually like so in blood-borne
proper for the longest time i tried my
damnedest to get turned into a beast
because like you have the beast the
beast meter and you know with the claws
and with taking like the forget if it's
the beast pellets or whatever there's
pellets you can tell yeah I could get it
boiled Alice I could get it up to like
95 percentage thinking like oh if I can
trigger a hundred percent I'll turn into
a beast come on I was like turns out it
was being saved for the for the
expansion
and that was awesome that you could turn
into a piece you can turn into something
else too
once you be an old hunter an old hunter
yeah turn into anyway thank dude what
was it monster honor recently had that
head that looked kind of the wiggly yeah
the Wiggly monster
I know Wiggly itchy is the bug you
collect okay yeah I played a lot of
monster on this weekend oh nice a game I
actually weirdly enough for some reason
I was telling Jake that it was a very
odd weekend I just played the division
for like eight hours no the the newest
stuff yeah so I was checking it out if
the update um you don't really notice
the early in game but once you get into
like what is it called resistance mode
it's like a horde mode yep pretty fun
the game is still I think it's much
better than when it started I think I
might do like a yeah a lot of people it
passed 20 million players this weekend
so I was like oh maybe I'll do a video
on it if I'd like it and I'm liking it I
don't love it I'd much rather play
matzah runner if I'm going to like those
loop those grind games uh-huh cuz
monitors fantastic the beauty of that
game I feel like and the reason why you
potentially why you you like it and
might even like it more down the road is
that it has a lot of it for maybe not a
lot it has Diablo 3 ties where it has
armor sets it has you know customizing
your weapon customizing your armor I saw
that a minute is terminal at the base
like download a high-level stuff and
they definitely have done a great job
like Ubisoft in general with some of
their games have done a great job like
kind of like weathering the storm of
lightning Rainbow six exactly right like
some of these games that were decent
solid on release not great right yeah
but somehow like as time has gone by you
know a year or whatever they found ways
to make the game a lot better
yeah Ghost Recon aminos I played a
little bit of that I play Ghost Recon
every once in a while with yeah Carl
Magnussen you know what I'm talking
about
broccoli man I didn't have the build I
really realize it though so computer
load up celery man please
HPS plus games come out a sparrow Mira
he's a tomorrow question why I believe
it is tomorrow yeah someone's got more
endurance your piece-of-shit man's now
says Mike what's happening with resident
evil with Mary miss you guys want to see
you guys play Code Veronica no news yet
I I thought like I stay in touch with I
mean I hang out with her and stuff when
we talk about it's just finding the
right time if that time comes sometime
soon as she knows we're talking about
her and I doing a I don't know if we
would do like I don't think it'd be a
Knievel specific panel at PAX West but
we want to do something like with tim
terry at capcom and like horror games in
general and evil probably factor into
that somehow obviously that's not until
August September Wade the McGinnis
reminding me that Eric do you mean games
as platforms yeah I guess technically
would you say oh it's just because I was
talking about the vision and Rainbow six
siege well okay that's I games a service
and I think a game service I think of
like lifestyle game like destiny they're
meant to keep you there they have it
like a daily event stuff and Rainbow six
has that but it's all aesthetic stuff
and it's not like a vision though the
division definitely I I get kind of
annoying people compare Rainbow six to
that because the division definitely
does as I'm trying to think like what
else I mean the division pulled you guys
off destiny for a little bit right you
in the destiny crew I think ma no more
division came up before destiny to yet
but I'm like pulled you off taking king
for a little bit Oh
time for like that week maybe a little
bit maybe a little bit Josh Josh Shaw
really like the division wanted to go
back but I just haven't I didn't so I
played on xbox right because that's what
we had available at the time and you
know everyone that I play games with
mainly or personally for me my
playstation you want to go could go
either way I could go either way
fight the cleric me says Guitar Hero
mastermind well you missed it he he
killed he smoked them Superman turn at
the end dead choreo slash n on maybe a
favorite boss in the game well who did
you say your favorite for me um that's a
good question I don't even let me think
about that
alright go for it ah just from like an
aesthetics point of view I might go lady
Maria cuz as people in chat said maybe
I'm a weed but Ludwig it was actually
cool fight this is really cool he's
[ __ ] hard despite him being a real
piece of crap like just yeah you just
have to experience that fight to kind of
like be like I'm like oh you know but
trying to think of blood-borne proper
German maybe I think pretty dope cuz I
like the whole time you're like oh I
despite the fact that they're easy for
me I like like I think I've honestly one
shot in every single time I'm the shadow
of yharnam I like them a lot just like I
like that like balance like it's just
natural for me to to look kind of like
separate them and then use that pillar
to stop the dude from hitting me with
range or like the long-ass snake arm
yeah I like shadow yharnam a lot like
you said from a design standpoint I
don't think they're the hardest at all
they're in fact are the easiest boss for
me aside from the witch in this game
gotcha
I want to kill this dude yeah as
mentioned it's is it is free for those
that have PlayStation Plus what we think
is prettier tomorrow but yeah as
chronium chaos says if you if you want
to support the game you can I think it's
$20 for just the base game not sure with
old hunters maybe 40 now maybe 30 I
don't know but yeah it's this is more of
you know I I always will find it I
always like a good excuse to come back
to playing a solid game guys like
or someone tomorrow tomorrow 6:00 yeah
operation chimera an outbreak go live
pump for that me and Jake got something
going up so it should be timed well with
that
me I don't want to follow up I always
fall off there yeah you're gonna have to
unlock the shortcut for a gas coin here
yeah stick around Guitar Hero mastermind
we will be doing Gascoigne for sure
before we end maybe a little bit more
about how about I do get to I don't
think it'll take me that much longer to
get the gas going and then I'll give it
to you see all right I let you do okay
after gas Killeen okay or I don't know
like maybe I'll just so for next time I
die or something actually how about that
next time I die great you're gonna
purpose a guy aren't you no I want to
play booster l hardy says I killed
Ludwick first try
that's impressive well that's the thing
like um I
there's bosses that some people have
yeah that [ __ ] with like that should I
kill shadow of yharnam every time what's
uh what's where those two asset hunters
in Dark Souls 3 I can't remember their
names what I killed them so easily the
first time I'll remember their name if
you put that up all right sure I can't
remember off the top of my head
[Music]
Assasin's is coming to mind for some
reason looking no because I beat them so
easily because remember their health
goes in oh you're talking about that oh
gosh the guys with the the fared great
sword the the guys that look like
Artorius kind of not really hunters it
look like hunter torn they work for
artorias the Great Wolf guys they're
dressed like I'm dressed right now
almost like they look like hunters big
hunters gosh somebody help me I'm gonna
get the music box
cuz you say you don't usually use the
music box you stagger him one day you
don't I like that stuff so I like it
when it's optional I don't like this
waters this watchers those guys are so
dope that the sound that varies it easy
for me they were hard for me yes
remember I beat them for one shot them
both times that's pretty good luck the
music for abyss Watchers is awesome if
you haven't listened to that song should
I recommend highly recommend oh god I
hate these lute and Dan says a king so
I'm pretty sure I beat Amidala the first
try that's that's pretty good too I
don't think I've ever bought personally
in blood-borne yeah shadow of yharnam I
always do yeah best Watchers I do I
really like the abyss watch also
actually I really like the ice dancers
name that falls from the cathedral
ceiling boreal the boreal you know to
the borealis valley or something no
that's fort of the boreal valley he's
the second boss are you talking about
the dance yeah you're right you're right
I like that one a lot
design-wise right those attacks are
always tough for me the sweeping ones
like Starbase she was one of the ones I
might have one shot but that's because I
had all that practice in the beta
he's like a boss well yeah cuz in the
beta and in the preview vents we all did
she was the first boss you fight so
we're like oh [ __ ] where'd she go when
we were reviewing the game yeah black
stars hanging I can't start really likes
to use PlayStation at this primary
consoles I mean for me personally like I
said earlier it's just my opinion but
that's where I play it Xbox all weekend
actually I was playing I'm doing like
something on hoard modes wave defense
business in so many games hustling gears
before and then I was I always go back
to halo I was my mess chief collection
it's probably the most used physical
copy I have
I mean it's just my preference of like
what games are available on
platform and namely this is one of the
top contenders okay so so that's where
the garb was and then the music box is
up that way okay okay
also for me personally I just gravitate
to where most of my you know friends
play on consoles so like that just
happens to be Playstation and like I
think the GameSpot office just that's
the easy it's just I think being his for
so streamline a lot of ways to play
online and I don't know I I love I love
Xbox games but I don't I have had a
problem with the Xbox one UI even if air
was updated I said it's more Windows 10
because obviously they're trying to make
Xbox one UI look like Windows 10 and I
just wish they wouldn't Xbox 360 was so
much better
gadget might wants to correct you on
your one shotting of the abyss watchers
because you can't actually 1-shot them
but you can first try them and he's
technically not all friends between one
shotting and first try what do you mean
because he's literally taking the like
literal term of you one shotting them
but they don't take yeah exactly I guess
but because what is the thing with them
don't doesn't their help start writing
or something like one of them dies right
this is my amends now they kind of they
kind of fight each other you can kind of
get them to fight each other they kind
of die right one of them dies and
there's one you eventually have to fight
one of them but then technically that
one after you like beat them the first
time you technically have to beat them
again yeah yeah cuz he kind of like gets
back up like super-powered or whatever
yeah so I like that I like that that's
that's good yeah the health reduction by
50% for the child sentence does kind of
suck they're pretty annoying but there
are some ways to circumvent that
trickster HD just so you know what's
them I don't know if you'll remember
this what is the most blood echoes
you've had it at once called remember
it's like I think mine was 250 K and
that was terrifying I've been in in
somewhere in that range to you because I
got some point you start farming them
and you just kinda like I don't want to
go back yet like one of the best yeah
one of the best things to farm are those
pigs and
and either like it for air and the force
or like way later down when you're like
at the very air you like they give you a
thousand each no it's like five or six
thousand Oh at least the end ones that
are like the crazy alien versions but
like yeah you're positing the lower the
lower ones apply two thousand there's
actually one right up ahead that you
could kind of yeah there's a way to
choose that one too by the way I don't
disagree with the Xbox controller hand
crampy thing or someone was saying these
get hand cramps with the PlayStation
controller versus the Xbox controller I
think the Xbox controller especially the
elite version is it feels a lot better
than a PlayStation controller me and Rob
both think that I mean I don't want to
speak for them then I might have missed
remember them I think they like the
switch pro controller better than
anything
yeah pro controller like you know I love
the ps4 Charlie I think the Xbox one
controller for I prefer shooters or if
I'm not playing like strategy games like
for first shooters as my two main genres
I'd say although I play everything
obviously but I like the Xbox soon I
used to hate the Xbox controller at
first it felt way too big because the
360 controller is smaller and like the
360 controller is almost perfection I
don't envy Microsoft having to improve
on that mm-hmm but they did a good job
well the I think the the thing for me
though is if I did have an Xbox one I
would definitely I mean it's really
expensive but I would definitely want a
league controller just because I could
sorry let the pig tunnel the pig is that
way like farther down were y'all but
this is the box oh you're gonna get the
music box okay sorry but you know what
happened if I'm not sorry those the
latter later near the pig to get to the
yeah to get toward guests going good
once to know you guys gonna rush bosses
here just explore it it's kind of like
boss slash exploring we're not we're not
there's nothing that we have set in
stone as to what we're trying to do here
blue tank Dan says I can so why did you
guys have trouble with Lawrence the
first vicar if he whooped my ass for a
whole month I swear it's a blue tank
game um you guys he gave me some
problems if I took me like I don't know
I can't remember I I definitely did
struggle with him a little bit cuz he
has some annoying moves and like the
fire is just really freakin annoying but
he did not put me in The Hurt box as
much as some other some other oh damn
that was dumb this guy is different to
you by the way
got more reach because the club is all
that is come at me [ __ ] this is
before guys gone right yes sir galahad
we're getting pretty close to attempting
us going here in a second it done he's
grabbing the music box to make to
showcase like how much it is how the
shortcuts also up here right it's not
the shortcut is not it's on the other
side this go this is the shortcut back
to the courtyard where you fight the
first troll dude yeah but there's not it
that's not this isn't the actual
shortcut no no I'm just a this is a
shortcut
okay sure and this goes back to central
yharnam yeah I thought I thought you
meant it as a shortcut to Gascoigne
no no that's yeah the pig thing oh now
you got to look for her mom though she's
at I don't have to she'll give me the
music box
oh okay I didn't find her mom and then
you come back and tell her mom's on the
roof neo that's where the red you jewel
is the Ruby that you get from guess I'll
be back down here for gas going yes yes
sorry what about gas going uh yeah the
lady you were just mentioning was where
you get the Ruby it's like hard the
house yeah and then you show the kid
yeah I forget what I'll then you also
get a bunch of echoes from that yeah and
she dude goob you were so over leveled
for everything you're fighting you were
like grinding your butt off and you're
like oh I killed this thing and I'm like
some people like doing that I know
that's that's part of the game yeah for
the game I just wanted to make the game
harder for him because he was like oh
this games so easy I'm like yeah you're
also like you got so much of life to
fight this boss sorry Pig is this way
right yeah baby straight ahead and then
if you want to avoid the pig you can
just go up this ladder up down here
right okay go up the ladder yeah like I
feel like I should have way more so that
goes right now but are you far oh you
[ __ ]
yeah wow that's pretty tough black sorry
good luck with that one he says when I
get the game I'm gonna try an ode I run
it's definitely possible there's
nightmares people that do that I like it
it's tough man are you gonna get a good
weapon the plays of mercy I think if I
killing the NPC I don't think he's gonna
kill well he's not even skilled based I
don't think too much so I think you're
like actually no you're pretty balanced
right you got a pretty bad line down one
mainly just like things that'll help me
right now skip Ilene for now waves of
Mercy is pretty sick weapon I just don't
like they're like a reach I think some
of the other skill weapons down the road
are better
personally I like the chikage and then I
like the rakuyo I think is what's called
the lady Maria weapon but you actually
have to like what's up that ladder
because just back up alright yeah he
doesn't start Oh is he only triggered
based off of this come on Tim but I feel
like I'm gonna be on the controller soon
come on Wow someone lost 1.3 farming
dungeons that's something crows know
that yes or echoes I wouldn't throw my
ps4 out the window or no I take it out
to a field and office space it ahem are
these live for now as motion no it's not
out the the free stuff doesn't come out
till tomorrow if that's what you're
asking mosey yes plus this tomorrow
high-pressure is oh do you know what's
funny is when you've just rolled these
guys you like literally are like
sticking your hand up its butt on me or
it looks like that so funny animation
the visceral or the back stab the back
steps are at the back of the backsides
sorry because like there's one that you
can sneak up to at the end towards the
end and yeah I've just rolled that one
all the time
it's very scary as like aa person
watching I remember when I had blow I
had I got blood-borne early the first
time I came out everybody that was that
had played to Dark Souls game was like
watching behind me and just like
frantically freaking out because I've
never played a souls game though what
are you doing I'm like I don't know well
that was what's it Kevin Ord reviewed it
right yeah but like lark was behind me
like no don't do that I don't like I
don't know what I'm doing man yeah the
pro does have the better like slightly
better frame rate if you turn it on are
we playing on a from now we're playing
on just normal ps4 there is something
that you can turn on the on the pro that
I believe that Gianluca tried and
there's a gameplay clip actually you're
falling down there no I have not did you
grab this off solder Matt yeah cool that
lets you buy something forget the sauce
beer things cost yeah
sir galahad saying a favorite boss for
them is Gascoigne before old hunters and
then lady Maria really and Vees do I
know the way yeah I think so hi will you
teach me the way [ __ ] good dodge are you
gonna get that shortcut
yeah how far do you have to be to play
co-op you just have to I already got the
whatever bell 100 spell okay so pretty
clear so after the first sorry you just
have to get inside I think it's the same
thing no you don't go that way
yeah you wanna go that way they should
all be did I get the echoes from them
I'm not sure because you're pretty far
away from them I didn't see like a trail
come back to you
I would don't listen to these guys I
have the pro remember the villa no place
where trust me the pro does enhance the
gameplay but only but why are you didn't
I just see that I just said the pro does
some stuff that make it better but not
like exponentially better what is Cody
said that come on I mean chaos is
trolling you i boost mode that's what
it's called thank you trickster HD yeah
and if there's one if there's a major
problem this game at all it's sometimes
the frame rate can be shitty Alden
Wakefield best strength-based weapon in
your opinion ooh hi do you have one best
weapon I think I have one over like you
mean is that even strength-based I think
so but I want to go with so you have to
do some stuff to get it high but who's
the priest that you talked to you in the
next area that gives you like flame
paper yeah the night the night oh [ __ ]
what am i doing his name oh my lord
hey I think his weapon is the best thing
based weapon is he it's like the crazy
like staff has a spinning wheel
um and that thing does crazy damage when
you yeah it's actually really hard I
think is really hard for me that's you
don't need to old hunters for that too
you know you don't year it's like a buzz
saw his name is Alfred and he has the
wheel hunter badge and I think his wheel
hunter new weapon is probably one of the
best strength weapons I think hey you
almost got the controller oh really
negligence on this guy dude if you
didn't oh wait you need to get this work
out so even if you died I'd be fine with
that that's okay I screw you over
yeah not really cuz I'd just be coming
here and then going back up top I'm
saying if I didn't get a shortcut oh
yeah yeah yeah that would be a really
annoying Ludwig is maybe a good shout to
Lou Wiggs is a pretty decent it's just
like all-around great weapon yeah do I
want to go back to lantern for now yeah
and then I'll go oh okay thank you crony
her nor iam fine that's fair he said it
was the chat not us I thought he was
calling me out I was like wait what I
don't know I think it no I was kidding
yeah you said the framerate was good
it's it's better it's not like
exponentially it's not like a huge
upgrade it's like it's a minor upgrade
measure WB dot o-- says ludwig sword
yeah so maybe we wait the lack of
hearing hurts me says Jonathan Manning
he already Mike already preface that
he's not a huge Perry guy he likes a
like you know to get in an attack
totally fine I they won't get your
parent yeah I got into pairing like my
second playthrough cuz I like I said I
having not played any souls game or
anything like that I did not want a
parry same with like um Dark Souls 3 I
did I definitely did Harry oh nice
you've met that right laborious wheel
Thank You Reich and blade yeah whirligig
soft yeah that thing dude he is a beast
have you fought him he like grabbed me
dude my like second or third playthrough
he wrecked me he wrecked me so bad that
guy's no joke and he is like he is a
crazy guy by the way if if you if you
get into that it's crazy guy that whole
story and like all that stuff is cool
because you can even bring back what's
her name after the fact which is awesome
because it's like oh no she he did his
thing and now what am I gonna do oh wait
I could bring her do an altar and bring
her in for life you guys can find out
about that that's like a whole nother
area that like I didn't know about the
first time playing through to that's
like crazy
oh that boss is hard oh one thing we
haven't yeah we didn't talked about the
Dark Souls on switch are you excited to
that I will probably play I will just I
don't even know I don't know if I'll be
able to play that game portable which is
the main a lure for switch but like I
can't imagine really I made and stuff no
not worried about that oh no no I'm
saying like the actual act of holding a
handheld thing like for when I play Doom
on switches like god it just doesn't
feel right like the switches great
portability wise and I think like
obviously if there is something to bring
it to its the switch but I just get so I
need a controller like the balance of a
controller oh okay I got you I got you I
got you yeah I just don't think I would
be that the pro controller is gonna feel
pretty good for that though yes I'm
saying that'll be fine but like
portability Wow okay one of the hardest
bosses pre old hunters was a Breda was
Brito is that the name of the thing
daughter of the cosmos did you fight
that thing
no oh man it shoots lasers oh yeah yeah
I had that you need the insight to even
see that one right yeah it's up top
I helped Dan Reichert when he was going
through blood-borne cuz he couldn't he
couldn't beat it and I was just like how
cool if you want to post it up helped
him help them kill it that was a fun
time that that boss sucks though it has
some moves that just like one shot you
and you can't really tell because it's
such a big monster that you can't really
tell when it like cues it up the move
which is which was kind of annoying but
whatever it's fine oh yes Cole J say
nothing more satisfying than using the
pistol rapiers that transform attack to
get a riposte yeah I I got one of those
pretty luckily with the there's like
yeah exactly the rapier kind of pistol
gun and I got and I comboed into it and
it was very satisfying don't forget he
was actually trouble I'm just gonna
bypass these - yeah martyr allegory Asst
goob he said the guy at the top of the
manor is pretty beast yeah some people
figured him out though I mean a lot of
people once he had those things that
come out of the sky you have to break
the sword stuff he would channel the
swords he also flew around like a
frickin a-hole yeah he was fun I like I
like pain hurts in general painters was
cool was a cool area for sure I know I
can get these echoes yeah she's got a
kind of like Batum you're probably not
gonna get the fireball probably won't
kill them all but hi all right let's see
chat puts her ones up if you think
Mike's gonna one-shot or you know first
try - coin like that and - if you don't
think he's gonna do it I personally
think he's gonna do it he's gonna not
he's not gonna make me go through it
although you're gonna are you gonna use
the music box
yeah I guess so you don't usually use it
you said right I have never used
I've never even gotten the music box of
a little girl I didn't even know it was
there I just actually before I forget
for me I I'll use the music box as
cheating I just think it's
for a gas going I'm pretty much got used
to up like a reposting him where gun
firing him oh yeah I so I do it with him
a lot I just there's not science to it I
kind of just do it and he attacks so
fast you kind of just randomly get it I
do it in both forms though yeah I do it
in his a the second one is easier I
think because he's attacking so fast but
Gascoigne
ain't no joke he he hurts does the look
of the area's change of it yeah they do
a lot of confidence yeah they definitely
do change well not as much in the
beginning TM but there are definitely
areas down the road that look quite a
bit different
well a lot of twos a lot of twos Mike
they'd and learn a few ones of the day
whatever kundo what matter he says sorry
the title is wrong this is the best ps4
game it's not wrong he's yeah I can't
debate that one maybe we can't me and
Mike cannot definitively say from
GameSpot that it is the best so well
we're going streaming yeah our personal
opinions count but I don't know if I
could get away with titling something
like blood-borne our reviews editor Pete
my best I don't know if he likes this
game how much you liked it I think he
likes this one was the one that was
probably the most accessible to him okay
no box no music box
no music box I'll go no music box are a
lot of twos though I'm like a lot more
twos than one that was Kevin Hoffman
well it any any anybody
yeah I'll avoid Cory asking what do you
guys think of co-op a lot of elitist in
the Diaz community I think that it's
it's it's a good thing to have for some
of the players that just want to kind of
get through the game and still enjoy and
not like totally rip their hair out but
as an elitist personal elitist I try to
do everything myself I think I beat
everything myself but here we go oh shut
up now
stop shooting me do this instead this
guy Mason hood says good luck my deed
later Wade I swear to god he reloads
faster than we do yeah oh he does does
everything faster I will say after gas
going whooped me with the ax my second
playthrough I started with an axe
because of gas coming yeah someone else
says no use the music box I've never
seen it
oh really [ __ ] whatever I don't I just
unequipped it it's fine he okay it's
just it literally just stuns him as if
you visceral attacked them and then you
although it gives you a few seconds
though because you have to actually like
let it play oh come on it's my blood
you're [ __ ] me up dick
actually I thought he was gonna say it's
fear he smells your fear like [ __ ] I ran
out of endurance that was my fault that
was very much my fault yeah I was about
to go pee to say anything well this is
kind of p2 when he goes studies the long
ax the trees help you out yeah oh you
[ __ ] oh there it is
oh [ __ ] my bad oh good I'll good oh that
was a good one you got me didn't hurt
that using these pretty literally just
cuz I have a lot we can always get more
that's not an issue
uh-oh let's do it
he's a madman this one I do the music
box come on come back to me and he also
doesn't give you time to heal really
yeah you really have to like item to get
to get that a deal off
god I hate his form
don't worry guys
anyone else Shh be quiet
don't talk endurance stamina sorry
Oh [ __ ] screams
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] we got you at the
three-hitter no I can I'll do it from
here all right damn plus I was whoo that
was making me I gotta get a little I'm
gonna kill some of these weaker guys to
get a little warmed up here yeah I'm
going in cold I'm right yeah all right
put your ones and twos if you think I
can kill guess cone one if you think I
can kill Gascoigne and two if you don't
think I can kill Gascoigne because now
I'm playing I think you got it I don't
know it's it's pretty nerve-wracking
when I know oh man this is it you know
why I'm sorry he's done monster hunter
hey r1 they're just the - there oh yeah
wait what yeah I want you hold our one
two - maybe on your controller severide
click the left stick all right r1 and
monster on for me is uh see I just I
just did it I just have my muscle memory
had me vile there when I meant to uh to
attack oh god this is gonna be a
interesting experience
alright I just gotta get used to it
it'll be fine
I'm giving myself an out guys alright
but you wanted that you guys wanted that
the visceral stuff so hey pretty even
amount you're getting a lot more ones
no no I'm pressing the wrong dodge
button - so what's the deal if you died
you had to go back to Mira I just let
you know I think so I think so I think
so my my I am so my buttons are our mess
- dude yeah beer on salut sorry if I'm
butchering that yeah we're we're playing
that because it's free on there yes plus
tomorrow I got I got it's coming back to
me you guys it come back to me look at
that mmm mmm he's dead he's dead and
then just you just ragdoll his ass
around but ragdoll you know I remember
in Dark Souls and Demon's Souls us I
don't know if it was like more intense
but it's always funny oh yeah if you
guys didn't know - you can press up on
the d-pad and get
bullets bo3 for life d 0:04 it'll be
available on PSN tomorrow we believe PS
plus for free Arwen our to circle is
dodge triangle is yeah i hear a lot of
people say that we think damage is
saying MA horizon after monster hunter
was a terror trying to figure out the
control scheme again horizon i always
had trouble with because it was so like
dodging was not to square i think
instead of circle if i'm not mistaken
and then obviously you have to like
figure out which which dial will change
his weapons which is arrows x2 nothing
in this game it's action the action
button how do i run again hold circle it
is circle all right should I just run by
these guys yeah yeah I'm with goober
come on give me the fireball you son of
a beating no go in that back Oh take it
start it's worth it was worth 100% worth
did you kill all of them no strong dang
you have like no endurance you Carl
alright well just farm up some vials off
this guy it'll be fine damn it oh no it
didn't do it Oh God
usually I do the hop thing like this and
then I yeah because that like almost
guarantees it I feel like hey I stay I'm
not used to doing the the jumping attack
to is it's just like up and you have to
run no you have to do a station you you
press up and art to its arts you Oh
strong all right what do what do we get
here some once or some twos what did I
bring that women split it's a few more
ones um they got confidence to you Sam
James saying favorite thing about this
game ID so again level design personally
the level design the way you can
actually like warps back in on itself
I'm gonna chose alright here we go
finally gets going I'll try to Oh get
those what is it like there's Lisa 707
well right now oh how is that not a
stagger it seems kind of arbitrary
sometimes oh sure come on fight me fight
me like a man using you with that
blunderbuss more like blender bro
there you go who's in this role game
will be free tomorrow we're pretty sure
is crazy surgeon five we've got
exchanged bullets they're a little
matrix action John wick this fight is
like a John wick scene shooting each
other point-blank I wanted to trade
nice so that was what I was kind of
talking about like with trading and
stuff yeah then you try to sneak that
one in you sneak that one while he's
getting up oh why already seems I prefer
him with the X with the long act you
head yeah but yeah so much more wheat
yeah but when you dodge he takes so much
longer to recover I'll shut up no no
yeah this is this is where you got
cheese and say please do another blood
well you got it Mike damn okay maybe I
shouldn't don't be conservative with him
there you go this pairing thing while
he's in the two-hand is a lot harder I
guess no yeah I think yeah I do a little
bit earlier I think that one's a leader
me oh good call there you go nice job
he's hit him while he does it yeah but
he pushes you away yeah you need like
three or four hits you're good you got
it just don't get that three or four hit
that he does here you want to know a
strat this is a shred of anyone someone
else was saying this - well like he's
way easier to stagger like up here yeah
whenever you show you're not around the
grave no he did the death from above
knew what an [ __ ] he also
accidentally pressed
l2 and said oh you're still going for
the stagger aren't you nice
hey guy you got this - wait ah still so
good
nice that it no oh maybe it's really
close if Naga nice good job
think I do this like every youtuber yeah
and you stare yeah I got that Ruby she's
like up here he's on that yeah right
there
search the body Oh later on - there's a
hunter that shows up over here and he's
kind of annoying to put some light the
lamp hey we did it we did y'all believe
there's a spot there I thought you might
might have had it
dude there was a one time I glitched him
out of the he like disappeared like
disappeared did and then like I thought
it glitched out where the game was gonna
freeze but literally like a minute after
it was like oh he's dead like okay he's
still had like a third of his life I
think but you know it's fine there's a
lady that shows up here later that you
can kind of do cool things with alright
I gotta do a hold circle what do you
think I should do just play like a
little bit like gets like one more area
and then try to think who the next boss
would be what Star Plus starved
have to like there's a big gap between
you got to do like old yeah I mean I
guess you could yeah we'd have to like
rush it or something I don't know
no it's not that close though alright
whatever
no you probably not important i buy we
work on four holy thanks soto
i'd like to think that but you know i
think i just skipped it on accident in
my bed then there's this guy oh another
pro tip never kill an npc unless you
have a save cuz you don't want to be
that you want to be stuck not having an
npc the rest of the key I get think the
doll you can kind of get away with cuz
she still works even though she's like
fake dead or knows what
now I can't get his rematch that's fine
he can always guess rematch by starting
a new game I be cleric with a Gascoigne
coop you know I was just trying oh yeah
oh you know can we I forget I don't
think I don't think we can yet though
right it's not unlocked it's gonna be
weird playing this if you play this game
online seeing the influx of other people
yeah they're so they're saying that
people are gonna come back I don't have
the key for it that's where you would go
to get Ludwig's blade though you have to
beat what's-his-name to get for that
door to open I forget can you stagger
the hell of big dudes oh here you go you
got the Jabbawockeez right here no
stagger oh you want me to stagger
no I meant like there's no knock back
you know who I'm talking about though
right there's really really big dudes I
can't remember I don't think you can't
uh no I don't I mean like the Giants up
here you don't really this is the area
where you would go for the old hunters
DLC it's like this tree right here once
you beat Emilia oh we could do Emilia
but she'll probably whip me oh yeah I
mean you could do that now if you want
to end this dream go try it oh why is it
taking me No did you see that yeah I
thought that it does that no matter what
yeah unless you need like at least five
inside or something I don't know um yeah
try Emilia and all right all right fine
can I go level up first
yeah Emilia Emilia has got some of those
like blood start be sweeping attacks
that are tough oh there it is not the
World League is that yeah that's a
whirly yes that's the that that is
definitely the whirligig someone saying
go blitz are beasts oh he's blessed our
beauties a lot farther than Emilia
Emilia is way quicker cuz you can just
run past oh god I keep holding our one
down she's way closer than blood star
blood starve is a while even if I rush
through to get the Blood star they would
be pretty far away wow I can only do one
level of sick Mike I'll take these wait
no you have a knee not hold I'm probably
do but it's fine
you know yeah
numbing mists before you get but the
only way to get the numbing miss is
either unless the store has it you have
to actually go through part of like the
playthrough to get it it's on the way
isn't it it's that dead body on the way
in the cathedral ward yeah I guess
that's true
I mean Tiger man is I keep forgetting a
Spider Man I'm I love insomniac but like
technically I don't know I hope that
game is good that fire paper would be
really good right now but I was good
spider-man games we can buy a fire pit
to cover you plugs yeah pizza cutter oh
yeah yeah unfortunately I can't get
fired paper okay I might be able to get
fire paper from Alfred but uh might take
too long
Oh we'll just we'll just Yolo I'll give
it my best shot
I'm not feeling too happy about it but
it's fine how do I hate oh man I don't
even remember how to is it if you just
r1 r1 into r2 does it trick the weapon
no you have to actually use you r1 r1
than l1 forward I think okay well I'll
just try it a night of night is this the
first time they are playing it no is not
I've been in it twice I haven't gotten
the crappiest ending how many times have
you played it how many times have you
beat it I guess you betta at least twice
I think is what you said earlier three
times and I'm like I'm at the one reborn
on my current playthrough
that's pretty far though that's like
three legs on your way the next boss is
right you don't have to fight Amidala
though evening so death we are gonna go
try Amelia I'm gonna die who knows see
how it goes but that's just the way what
I do that I'm gonna die yeah that's fine
what are you die unequipped my pistol
press the left doubt you did you bring
your torch out no I have throwing match
it's late now the pistol and throwing
knives wouldn't be in the same slot it
would be I think you accidentally press
left on the d-pad I probably did well
that went well guys didn't die - gasps
Cohn died - random guy because
I yeah it's fine I know I'd say I'll
throw up a 2 for Amelia but I think
you'll be I think you'll get depressed
oh you know what I pressed the wrong
button spider-man rumored for September
I can't confirm or deny that but that
sounds right God of War Pete on ps4 this
year who knows how that'll turn out I
just press the wrong button
I mean idiot what else my ps4 God of War
spider-man The Last of Us to do that I
don't think that'll be this year
maybe oh we can't get to Amelia I need
like 20 thousand souls oh you need the
the chapel key or whatever it is the no
the badge right or whatever is called
the badge of the old it's something that
you have to buy yeah it's 10,000 Souls
that's why blood Starfire comes there's
no shortcut right like I can't unlock it
I don't think has to Bluffs our beasts
there is no yeah you Vento there's a
shield eventually you open that up I
don't think I can yeah a trickster HD
we're just saying that thing all right
you know what we'll go fight those big
guys and then we'll call it stream then
I guess because I know this is like it's
honestly the biggest gap between bosses
in this game I mean all the yharnam and
all that and we can get to that bottom
area I guess even now take a while
thanks al and Detroit Thank You Corey I
don't have any interest in that game
from person Troy it is me right I
believe something like that yeah I
played heavy rain once never played
beyond heavy rain didn't really do it
for me come on no I like the atmosphere
heavy rain a lot
I was almost not worth it sometimes you
get to trigger out or I get to trigger
happy alright so one of the big dudes is
definitely here I'm pretty sure you
can't stagger these guys there's dude
back sad yeah curious back step from
what I remember as much easier in
doctors role you think so
I always I just never wanted to like
queue it up you know I know this
annoying question epic epic chaos says
but if I'm should I get this if I'm
really into this type of game it depends
what you mean by this type of game you
mean like character action this is a
little more intense than that but if
you're into like Dark Souls and yeah for
sure I mean it's free you have nothing
to lose by oh god I'm doing downloading
this tomorrow if you have PS plus I'm
trying it out fur I'm really not into
okay that makes more sense
um I don't know like Eric said he wasn't
super into this kind of game before he
played this and this got him into that
kind of game so maybe this will be the
same game for you I mean especially
since it's free you're gonna get the
opportunity yeah I don't think have
anything to lose by trying it out so I
just did that thing where like you know
like the guy is really close to dying
and you're just trying to spam to kill
him and then you don't kill him and then
you just get rekt I almost died because
that oh come on
game oh great yeah if you start swinging
too early it just doesn't register as a
visceral oh one of these dudes as the
club he's going away yeah yeah yeah you
guys are latched Oh God
oh he killed me damn won't call it no I
let me kill that guy I want to kill that
guy in particular that goes back Souls I
don't know this is this is the silly
part where it's like just dynasty I just
want to kill that one guy Mauro's Damian
the sixth of every month is when PS Plus
games go free is it always a six or
maybe it's the first Tuesday maybe but
it's tomorrow regardless it's kind of
like walk into him for a second and then
let it go I guess stupid you know ps+
well it's $20 if you don't I mean the
game itself blood-borne is but uh yeah I
mean how much does PlayStation Plus now
like is it still 50 per year yeah I
think so
sometimes it oh God well this year this
month is blood-borne and what else is
either your ratchet and clank oh yeah
ratchet Clank remake then that game is
really good retching Clank is one of my
favorite series that you know you don't
get to talk about enough nowadays but
the remake is fantastic and you should
play it
always hated the bigger guys Mike as I
can't staggering
thank God and you went long saw now I
just did it just oh we're farming shards
though yeah at about $60 why would it be
$60 for you right that doesn't make
sense maybe not in the US I mean so 60
USD come on yeah why is it 60 at Kaos
I'm just curious wrap it please be still
immune that God might not have gone down
in another country you think Oh
got my souls back though or my echo
Scott why are you yeah why are you over
here what I want that guy I'll kill you
two after a little bit Mike no
look at that look at that Alex Vasquez
said you can stagger them you just need
to attack a single leg I'm assuming in
reference to the larger dude no grave
giant sort of they're called oh that was
not worth it here just died
oh that's staggered him hilarious
alright give me those about alright I'll
get my rematch with this guy hey do it
yeah get out of here you stupid Birds
yeah they're so annoying
just giving you pebbles all the time
another very small chance they'll give
you a vial but a pebbles are good for
like all right what I got I got what -
just like pool people you know like you
can use the pebbles to like pull them
away so you don't fight them as many
guys don't anyway it's kind of like dung
and monster
well opposite yeah dung has a good
purpose of like getting the other thing
to run away but anyways yeah that's
blood-borne glad you guys were able to
join us and make sure if you guys have
PlayStation Plus and you don't already
own the game that you get you pick it up
tomorrow because it's available I think
it's one I'm like and i's favorite ps4
games to date at least that's what's
coming out on ps4 any last thoughts Wang
know you should play this even if you're
not like Eric said if you're not super
into this kind of in like a Souls born
person this game could get you into it
just because uh I mean it's it's great
for so many reasons but give it a chance
tomorrow if you have ps+ yeah even if
you don't want to give this a chance
retching Clank is also that's all it was
a game yeah so maybe maybe if you don't
have PlayStation Plus those two games
are well worth it and I think I think
Aaron was saying too that they've kind
of dropped the Vita ps3 part of that
like free game stuff so like you know
maybe more reason to have that now for
for future to PlayStation Plus that is
but until tomorrow we're we're probably
back with Rainbow six siege operation
chimera and outbreak we'll see you guys
tomorrow
thanks again later